The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
EERO SIMONCELLI: I'm going
to talk about a bunch of work
that we've been
doing over the last--
it's about four years, on
trying to understand basically,
that terra incognita that
Gabrielle just mentioned
that lies between V1 and IT.
I brought this back with
me from the Dolomites,
where I was last
week with my family.
And when you sit
and you look at it
and that image
comes into your eyes
and gets processed
by your brain,
there's a lot of
information there.
It's a lot of pixels.
And the question that
I'm going to start with
is, where does it go?
You have all this information.
It's flooding into your
eyes all day every day
for your entire lifetime.
Obviously, you don't
store it all there.
Your head doesn't
inflate until it
gets to the point of explosion.
So where does it go?
And as a theorist's
diagram of the brain--
a square with rounded corners.
In comes the information,
and there are really
only three options.
You either act on
the information,
do something with it,
sensory motor loops,
or for complex organisms
especially, a fair amount of it
you might actually
try to remember.
You might hold on to, and we
heard about that earlier today.
But this really
only accounts for, I
think, a fairly
small portion of what
goes on, because a lot
of it you throw away.
You have to.
You really don't have a choice.
You have to summarize
it, squeeze it
down to the relevant bits that
you're going to hold on to
or act on, and the rest
of it you just toss.
So the question is, how can
we exploit that basic fact?
It's an obvious fact.
It has to be true.
How do we exploit that
to understand something
about what the system does
and what it doesn't do?
And there's a long
history to this,
and in fact, since I come from
vision and most of my work
is centered on vision and
auditory system to some extent,
the vision scientists were
the first to recognize
the importance of this.
And it really is a
foundational chunk
of work in the beginning
of the field that
set in motion a lot of
things that we currently
know about vision.
And so I'm going to just--
for those of you that
don't know that story,
I'm going to give
a very, very brief
reminder of what
that is, because I
think it's an absolutely
fantastic scientific story.
And then from there,
I'll talk about texture.
So two examples-- I'm
going to quickly say
something about
trichomatic color vision,
and then I'm going to
talk about texture,
and then we'll go into V2 and
metamers and other things.
So trichromacy--
Newton figured out
that light comes in wavelengths.
He split light with a prism.
There's the picture drawing
of him splitting light coming
in through a hole in the wall.
He split it with a prism into
wavelengths, saw a rainbow,
did a lot of
experiments to recognize
that you could take that
rainbow and reassemble it
into white light, but you
couldn't further subdivide it,
and basically gave
us the foundations
for thinking about light
and spectral distributions.
In the 1800s, a
group of people that
were combined physicists,
mathematicians,
and psychologists
all rolled into one--
and there were
quite a few of them.
Helmholtz was one of them.
Grassmann was one of
the most important ones.
I'll mention him
again in a moment--
figured out something
peculiar about human vision--
that even though there was
this huge array of colors
in the wavelengths
in the spectrum,
that humans actually had these
deficits that we were not
able to actually sense
or discriminate things
that it seemed like
we should be able to.
And it boiled down in
the end, after a lot
of study and discussion
and theorizing,
to this experiment, which is
known as a bipartite color
matching experiment.
So on the left side of
this little display,
here's a gray annulus.
In the middle is a circle.
On the left side of this is
light coming from some source.
It has some spectral
distribution illustrated here.
This is all a cartoon,
but just to give you
the idea of how this works.
On the right side are
three primary lights.
And the job of the observer in
this experiment is to adjust,
let's say, sliders
or knobs in order
to change the intensity
of these three lights
to make the light on the right
side of this split circle
look the same as the
light on the left side.
And it turns out that--
so just to be clear,
so these three things
have their own
spectral distributions.
They might look like
that, for example.
And when the observer comes
up with the knob settings,
they're going to
produce something
that might look like that.
This is just a sum of the
three copies of these spectra
weighted by the knob settings.
So this is a linear
combination of three
spectral distributions.
And intentionally,
I've drawn this
so that they don't
look the same,
because that's the whole
point of the experiment.
It turns out that humans--
you can do this experiment,
and that any human
with normal color vision
can make these settings so
that these two things are
absolutely indistinguishable.
They look identical, and yet
they knew even in the mid-1800s
that these two things have
very different spectra,
and I've drawn it that
way intentionally.
So the point is that
humans are obviously--
even though we can see all
the bands of the spectrum,
we can see all the colors--
we actually have this
deficiency in terms
of noticing the difference
between these two things.
So how can that be?
And I think and hope
that most of you
know the answer
to that question,
because you're using
devices every day
that are exploiting this fact.
But the bottom line is that in
the 1850s Grassmann laid down
a set of rules.
Grassmann was a mathematician.
He actually developed a
large chunk of linear algebra
in order to explain and
understand and manipulate
these ideas.
And he pointed out that--
he actually had a set of
laws that he laid out,
and I won't drag you
through all of that.
But in the end, what
all of those laws
amounted to, taking into account
all of the evidence that he
had, he laid down these laws.
And what it amounted to
is that the human being,
when setting these knobs, was
acting like a linear system.
The human was taking an input,
which is a wavelength spectrum,
and adjusting the knobs.
And the settings of the
knobs were a linear function
of the wavelength spectrum
that was coming into the eye.
And it's a remarkable
and amazing fact,
if you know that the brain is
a highly non-linear device, how
is it that a human can
act like a linear device?
And the answer is that basically
the human, taking this thing in
and making the knob settings,
has a front end that's linear
and is doing a projection
of the wavelength spectrum
onto basically three axes.
And those three measurements--
that process is linear.
Everything that
happens after that,
which is complicated and
non-linear and involves noise
and decisions and all kinds of
motor control and everything
else--
as long as the information
in those original three
measurements is not
lost, then the human
is going to basically
act like a linear system,
in terms of doing this matching.
So Grassmann realized this.
The theory that he set out and
that others then elaborated on
perfectly explained all the
data for normal human subjects,
that lights that appear
identical but had physically
distinct wavelength
spectra could be created,
and they called these metamers--
two things that are physically
different but look the same.
This was codified.
It took many, many decades.
Things moved slower back then.
We don't have these rapid,
Google-style overturns
of scientific establishment
within a year or two.
It took until the 1930s
to actually build this
into a set of standards that
were used in the engineering
community to generate and
create color film, color
devices, eventually color
video, color monitors, color
projectors, color printers--
everything else that we use.
And these specifications were
to allow the reproduction
of colors so that they
looked the way they
were supposed to look.
So you record color
with a camera.
It turns out that your camera is
also only recording three color
channels, just like
your eye, and then you
have to be able to re-render
that on another device.
And these standards
specify how to do that.
The surprising thing
in the whole story
is-- so this is 1850s.
Well, we go back to Newton.
It was a 1600s.
Then in the 1850s, when we're
getting this beautiful theory
that's very, very
precise, this gets built
into engineering standards.
And it's not until
1987 that it actually
gets verified in a
mechanistic sense.
And I like to tell
this story, because I
think it's a reminder
that aiming always
for the reductionist solution is
not necessarily the right thing
to do.
This is a very beautiful
piece of science
that was done at
Stanford, actually,
by Baylor, Nunn, and Schnapf.
They took cones from a macaque--
I think originally they worked
with turtles, but then macaque,
sucked them up into a
glass micro-pipette,
shined monochromatic
lights through them,
and measured their
absorption properties.
And they found these
three functions
for three different types
of cones and verified,
basically, that these three
absorption spectra perfectly
explained the data
from the 1800s.
So this is an
amazing thing, if you
can have a theory and a set
of behavioral experiments
that make very precise and
clear predictions that then get
verified and tested
in a mechanistic sense
more than 100 years later,
and they come out basically
perfect.
So it's an astounding,
astounding sequence,
in my view.
So what we wanted
to do is to set out
trying to do the same kind
of thing for pattern vision.
And we're going to do that
by thinking about texture.
So what's a texture?
A texture is an image
that's homogeneous
with repeated structures.
So each of these are
examples of texture.
That's a piece of woven basket.
This is tree bark.
That's a herringbone
pattern, and these are
some sort of nuts or stones.
And each of these
has the property
that there's lots of repeated
elements with some variability.
Sometimes there's
more variability,
sometimes there's
less variability,
but there's usually
at least some.
And of course, these
things are ubiquitous.
When I started working on this,
which is about 15 years ago--
maybe a little bit
more, 16 years ago--
I started photographing things
that I saw as I walked around,
and textures are everywhere.
Most things are textured.
The world is not
made up of plain--
of Mondrians.
It's not made up of
things that are plain,
blank colors separated
by sharp edges.
It's made up of
textures, and often
the boundaries between things
are boundaries between things
that are textured objects, like
the seats in the auditorium,
for example.
So how is it that we can go
about thinking about this
in terms of metamers and
representation in, let's say,
the visual system?
And the idea really
comes from Julesz,
who proposed in 1962 a famous
theory that he later abandoned.
The theory goes like this.
First of all, he said
the thing that we're
going to do to try to
describe textures is
we're going to use statistics.
And why statistics?
Because these are
supposed to be variables,
so I need some stochasticity.
But I also want something
that's homogeneous,
so I'm going to average
or measure things averaged
across the entire image.
That's the statistical
side of it.
And he proposed that, well, if
I start by measuring just pixel
statistics-- say single
pixel statistics,
pairwise pixels statistics,
maybe triples of pixels,
eventually I should reach a
point where I've made enough
measurements to actually
sufficiently constrain
the texture such that any two
textures that have the same
statistics up to that--
whatever that order is, should
look the same to a human being.
And he didn't talk about
this in physiological terms,
but I think in the background
is the notion that humans
are actually measuring
those statistics,
and if you can get them right--
if you can make two images have
the same statistics, and that's
the only thing that humans
are measuring, then those two
images will look the same.
So Julesz goes ahead with
this, and eventually constructs
by hand, because
he did everything
with binary patterns
constructed by hand--
he constructs these two
examples that are identical.
He first falsifies the
theory at n equals 2,
and then he tries to do
third-order statistics.
And he comes up with these two
examples-- counter-examples
to the theory.
These are matched in terms of
their third-order statistics.
It's not easy to see that or
realize that, but it's true.
If you take triples
of pixels, and you
take the product of those
three, and you average
that over the image, these
two things are identical,
but they look very different.
And if you draw samples
of each of these,
it's very easy to label
them as, let's say, A or B
into these two categories.
Here's another
example that came out
a bit later by Jack Yellott.
These two things also are
matched up to third-order.
So Julesz decides that
the theory is a failure,
and he abandons it.
And he begins a new theory,
which is the theory of textons,
which is a much less
precisely-specified theory that
has to do with laying down--
basically, it's a generative
model, if you like.
Everybody's fond of
generative models
these days, except for me.
And he comes up with
a generative model--
ah, and maybe Tommy.
He comes up with the
generative model,
which is to lay down many copies
of a small, repeating unit,
which he called the texton.
And so he came up with this
method of generating texture
images, which he
went to town on,
and he made lots of examples.
The problem is that that
wasn't a description of how
to analyze texture images or how
a human would analyze texture
images, and so it became very
difficult to bridge that gap.
And I think, in my view,
that the theory really never
succeeded, and he should have
stuck with the initial theory.
Anyway, but that gave
us an opportunity.
So we went back
many years later--
this is around 1999.
I had a fantastic
post-doc, Javier Portilla,
who came from Spain, and we
started thinking about texture
and started putting
together a model that
was Juleszian in spirit,
but a little bit different,
because we wanted to build
in a little bit of what
we knew about physiology.
Now, Julesz knew
about physiology,
because Hubel and Wiesel were
doing all those experiments
in V1 in the late '50S
and the early '60s,
but he really didn't incorporate
that into his thinking.
So what we did is build
a very simple model.
It's just dumb, stupid,
simple, in which we took
this description of V1 neurons.
So these are oriented
receptive fields.
The idea is that this is a
description of a neuron that
takes a weighted
sum of the pixels
with positive and
negative lobes.
And it has a
preferred orientation,
because the positive
and negative lobes
have a particular
oriented structure.
And then it takes the
output of that weighted sum
and runs it through some
rectifying, nonlinear function.
And here's another, and
this is a classic thing
that Hubel and Wiesel
described for a simple cell.
And here's another one,
which is a complex cell.
And this one basically does
two of these and combines them.
I'm trying to avoid
the details here,
because they're not
critical for understanding
what going to show you.
So then we took those
things and we said, well,
what if we measure joint
statistics of those things
over the image?
So we're going to take
not just these filters,
but of course, we're
going to do a convolution.
That is, we're going
to compute the response
of this weighted sum
at different positions
throughout the image.
We're going to
rectify all of them.
Now we're going to
take joint statistics.
What do I mean by that?
Just correlations, basically--
second-order statistics
of the simple cells,
of the complex cells,
of the cross statistics
between them.
And these statistics are
between different orientations
and different positions
and also different sizes.
And given that large
set of numbers--
and typically for the images
that we worked with back then,
these were typically on
the order of 700 numbers.
So we have an image over here,
which is say, tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands of
pixels, being transformed
through this box into a set
of, let's say, 700 numbers.
So 700 summary statistics
to describe this pattern.
And then the question is,
how do we test the model?
And for testing the model--
most people, when they
test models like this,
they do classification.
This should sound very
familiar these days,
with the deep network world.
They take a model, and then
they run it on lots of examples.
And they ask, well,
do the examples that
are supposed to be the
same kind of thing,
like the same tree bark--
do they come out with
statistics that are similar
or almost the same
as each other?
And can I classify or
group them or cluster them
and get the right answer
when trying to identify
the different examples?
We decided that that was a
very-- at least at the time,
a very weak test of
this model, because this
is a high-dimensional
space, and we had only,
let's say, on the order of
hundreds of example textures.
And hundreds of-- that sounds
like a lot of textures--
a couple hundred textures,
but if the outputs
live in a 700 dimensional space,
then it's basically nothing.
We're not filling that space.
And for those of you that
are statistically-oriented,
you know that there's
this thing called
the curse of dimensionality.
The number of data samples that
you need to fill up a space
goes up exponentially with
the number of dimensions.
So this was really
bad news, and we
decided that it was
going to be a disaster
to just do classification--
that pretty
much any set of measurements
would work for classification.
So we were looking for a more
demanding test of the model.
And for that, we
turned to synthesis.
So the idea is like this.
So you take this image.
You run it through the model.
You get your responses.
Now we're going to take
a patch of white noise.
We're going to run it
through the same model,
and then we're going to lean
on the noise, push on it--
push on all the pixels
in that noise image
until we get the same outputs.
So this is sometimes called
synthesis by analysis.
This is not a generative
model, but we're using it
like a generative model.
We're going to draw
samples of images
that have the same
statistics by starting
with white noise and
just pounding on it
until it looks right.
And pounding on it
means, for those of you
that want to know, measuring
the gradients of the deviation
away from the desired
output and just moving
in the direction
of the gradient.
I'm giving you the
quick version of this.
A little bit more abstractly,
we can think of it this way.
There's a space of
all possible images.
Here's the original image.
It's a point in this space.
We compute the
responses of the model,
which is a lower dimensional
space-- a smaller space.
That's this.
Because this is a many to one
mapping and it's continuous,
there's actually a manifold--
a continuous a collection of
images over here, all of which
have the same exact
model responses.
And what we're trying to
do is grab one of these.
We want to draw a sample
from that manifold.
If the theory is right-- if this
model is a good representation
of what humans see and capture
when they look at textures,
then all of these things
should look the same.
That's the hypothesis.
And the way we do it, again,
is to start with a noise seed--
just an image filled with noise.
We project it onto the manifold.
We push it onto this point.
We can test that, because
we can, of course, measure
the same things on this
image and make sure
that they're the
same as this image,
and that's our
synthesized image.
So that's a abstract
picture of what I told you
on the previous slide.
And then finally, the
scientific or experimental logic
is to test this by showing
it to a human observer.
So we have the original
image, and then
we compute the model responses.
We generate a new image,
and we ask the human,
do these look the same?
And if the model captures
the same properties
as the visual system,
then two images
with identical model
responses should
appear identical to a human.
So that's the logic.
And any strong failure
of this indicates
that the model is insufficient
to capture what is
important about these images.
So it works, or I wouldn't
be telling you about it.
Here is just a few examples.
There are hundreds
more on the web page
that describes this work.
On the top are
original photographs--
lizard skin, plaster
of some sort, beans.
On the bottom are synthesized
versions of these.
The lizard skin
works really well.
The plaster works quite well.
The beans a little less so.
And it depends-- whether it
works well or not depends
on the viewing condition.
So if you flash
these up quickly,
people might be convinced that
they all look really great.
If you allow them to
inspect them carefully,
they can start to see deviations
or funny little artifacts.
So it's a partial success.
And I should point
out that it also
provides a pretty convincing
success on Julesz'
counter-examples.
So these are examples.
This is synthesized
from that, and this
is synthesized from that, and
they're easily classifiable.
And there's fun things
you can do with this.
You can fill in
regions around images.
So if you take this
little chunk of text here
and you measure the
statistics, and you say, fill
in the stuff around
it with something
with has the same
statistics, but try
to do a careful job of
matching up at the boundaries,
you can create things like this.
So you can read the
words in the center,
but the outside
looks like gibberish.
Each one of these was
created in the same way.
So the center of each of
these is the original image,
and what's around
it is synthesized.
So it works reasonably well.
You can also do fun
things like this.
So these are examples where--
I told you we started
from white noise,
and then pushed it
onto the manifold,
but we can actually
start from any image.
So if we start
from these images--
these are three of
my collaborators--
two of my students and my
collaborator Tony Movshon.
If we start with those
as starting point images,
and we use these textures
for each of them,
we arrive at these images,
where you can still
see some of the global
structure of the face.
Because the model is
a homogeneous model,
it doesn't impose anything
on global structure.
And so if you seed
it with something
that has particular global
structure or arrangement,
it will inherit some of that.
It'll hold onto it.
Anyway, this is just for fun.
Let's get back to science.
So now, here's an example
of Richard Feynman.
This is Richard Feynman after
he's gone through the blender.
You can see pieces of skin-like
things and folds and flaps,
but it's all disorganized.
Again it's a homogeneous model.
It doesn't know anything
about the global organization
of this photograph.
But what we want to know is--
so do we have a
model that's just
a model for the perception
of homogeneous textures,
or can we actually
push it a little bit
and make it, first of all,
a little more physiological,
and second of all, maybe
a little bit more relevant
for everyday vision?
For me, standing here and
looking at this scene,
how do I go about
describing something
like this that's going on when
I'm looking at a normal scene?
So let's go through thinking
about how to do this.
So I'm going to jump right
to this diagram of the brain
again.
So V1 is in the
back of the brain.
The information that
comes into your eyes
goes through the retina,
the LGN, back to V1.
And then it splits into these
two branches, the dorsal
and the ventral stream.
The ventral stream is usually
associated with spatial form
and recognition and memory.
So I'm going to think
about the ventral stream,
and we're going to
try to understand
what this model might have
to say about processing
in the ventral stream.
I'm going to rely on just
a few simple assumptions.
First, that each of
these areas has neurons,
and that they respond
to small contents
or regions of the visual input.
They're known as
receptive fields.
Most of you know that.
In each visual area,
I'm going to assume
that those receptive
fields are covering,
blanketing the
entire visual field.
So there's no dead spots.
There's no spots
that are left out.
Everything is covered nicely.
And in fact, we know that
this is true, for example,
starting in the retina.
So this is a cartoon diagram
to illustrate the inhomogeneity
that's found in the retina.
So the receptive field
sizes in the retina
grow with eccentricity.
And it turns out that
that starts in the retina,
but that's true,
actually, all the way
through the visual system and
throughout the ventral stream,
in particular.
And this diagram is showing
these little circles are
about 10 times the size of
your midget ganglion cell
receptive fields in your retina.
So you looking-- if
you fixate right here
in the center of
this, these things
are about 10 times the size
of your receptive fields.
And that's been
long thought to be
the primary driver of
your limits on acuity,
in terms of peripheral vision.
So in particular,
if you take this eye
chart, which is modified by--
this was done by Richard
Anstis back in the '70s,
and you lay it out
in this fashion,
these things are about
10 times the threshold
for visibility and
recognition of these letters.
And so you can say that the
stroke widths of the letters
are about matched to the
size of these ganglion cells,
and it works, at least
qualitatively-- that things
are scaling in the right
way, in terms of acuity,
and in terms of the size
that the letters need to be
for you to recognize them.
And you can make
pictures like this.
This is after Bill Geisler, who
showed that if you foveate--
if you fixate here,
in fact, you can't
see the details of
the stuff that's
far from your fixation
point, and if you blur it,
people don't notice.
You can actually add high
frequency noise to it,
alternatively, and people
won't notice that either.
Because those receptive fields
are getting larger and larger,
and you're basically
blurring out
the information that would
allow you to distinguish,
let's say, these two things.
When you look right
at it you can see it,
but if you keep your eye fixated
here, you won't notice it.
So let's work off
of those ideas--
the idea of these
receptive fields
that are getting larger with
eccentricity, that are covering
the entire visual field.
And let's notice the following--
so this is data taken--
physiological data
from several papers
that were assembled
by Jeremy Freeman, who
was a grad student in my lab.
And here you can see the
center of the receptor fields
versus the size of
the receptive fields.
And you can see
that in the retina--
I already showed you
on the previous slide
that it grows with eccentricity,
but it's actually very slow
compared to what
happens in the cortex.
V1, the receptor fields
grow at a pretty good clip.
V2, they grow about twice as
fast as that, and V4 twice
as fast again.
Another way of saying this--
at any given receptive field
location relative to the fovea--
let's say 15 degrees, the
receptive fields in V1
are of a given size.
It's on the order of
0.2 to 0.25 times.
The diameter is 0.2 to 0.25
times the eccentricity.
The receptive fields
in V2 are twice
that size, so about 0.45
times the eccentricity,
and the receptive fields
in V4 are twice that again.
In cartoon form, it looks
something like this.
So here's V1.
Lots of cells and
small-ish receptive
fields growing
with eccentricity.
Here's V2.
They're bigger.
They grow faster.
Here's V4.
And by the time you get to IT--
Jim DiCarlo was here
a bunch of days ago,
and he probably told
you this-- almost
every IT cell includes the fovea
as part of its receptive field.
They're very large,
and they often
cover half the visual field.
So now we have to
figure out what
to put inside of
these little circles
in order to make
a model, and I'm
going to basically combine--
smash together the texture
model that I told you about,
which was a global homogeneous
model, with this receptive
field model.
I'm going to basically stick
a little texture model in each
of these little circles.
That's the concept.
So how do we do that?
Well, we're going to go
back to Hubel and Wiesel.
Hubel and Wiesel
were the ones that
said you make V1 receptive field
simple cells out of LGN cells
by just taking a bunch of
LGN cells that line up.
Here they are-- center surround
receptive fields from the LGN,
which are coming
off of the center
surround architecture
of the retina.
You line them up, you
add them together,
and that gives you an oriented
receptive field, like the ones
that I showed you earlier.
And in more of a
computational diagram,
you might draw it like this.
So here's an array of
LGN inputs coming in.
We're going to take a
weighted sum of those.
Black is negative.
White is positive.
So we add up these three
guys, we subtract the two
guys on either side,
and then we run that
through a rectifying
nonlinearity
that's a simple cell.
Hubel and Wiesel
also pointed out
that you could maybe create--
or suggested that you
create complex cells
by combining simple cells.
This is the diagram from
their paper in 1962.
And so we can diagram
that like this.
Here's basically three
of these simple cells.
They're displaced in
position, but they
have the same orientation.
We halfway rectify all of
them, add them together,
and that gives us
a complex cell.
So it's interesting to
note that the hook here
is going to be that this
is an average of these.
An average is a statistic.
It's a local average.
So we're going to
compute local averages,
and we're going to call those
statistics-- i.e. statistics,
as in used in the texture model.
So let's do that.
So here's the V2
receptive field.
Open that up.
Inside of that is a bunch
of V1 cells, here all shown
at the same orientation.
In reality, they would be
all different orientations
and different sizes.
And now we're going to compute
those joint statistics, just
like I did in the
texture model, and that's
going to give us our responses.
We're going to have to do that
for each one of these receptive
fields.
So there's a lot of these.
It's not 700 numbers anymore.
It's reduced, because it's--
so there's details here.
It's reduced, but there's
a lot of these, so it's
quite a lot of parameters.
And these local
correlations that I told you
we were going to compute here
can be re-expressed, actually,
in a form that looks just like
the simple and complex cell
calculations that I
showed you for V1.
So in fact, if you
take these V1 cells,
and you take weighted
sums of these guys,
and you half-wave rectify
them and add them,
you get something
that's essentially
equivalent to the texture
model that I told you about.
So that's pretty
cool, because it
means that the calculations
that are taking us from the LGN
input to V1 outputs have a
form, a structure which is then
repeated when we get to V2.
We do the same kind of
calculations-- linear filters,
rectification,
pooling or averaging.
And so that, of
course, has become
ubiquitous with the advent of
all the deep network stuff.
But the idea here is
that we can actually
do this kind of canonical
computation again and again
and again and produce
something that
replicates the
loss of information
and the extraction of
features or parameters
that the human visual
system is performing.
So this canonical idea,
I think, is important,
and it's something that
we've been thinking
about for a long time--
linear filtering that
determines pattern selectivity,
some sort of rectifying
non-linearity,
some sort of pooling.
And we usually also include
some sort of local gain control,
which seems to be ubiquitous
throughout the visual system
and the auditory system in
every stage, and noise, as well.
And we're currently, in my lab,
working on lots of models that
are trying to incorporate all
of these things in stacked
networks-- small numbers of
layers, not deep-- shallow,
shallow networks for us--
in order to try to
understand their implications
for perception and physiology.
This was just a description
of a single stage,
and then, of course,
you have to stack them.
And there are many people that
have talked about that idea.
This is a figure from Tommy's
paper with Christof, I think--
1999.
And Fukushima had proposed
a basic architecture
like this earlier.
And so I think this
has now become--
you barely even need to say
it, because of the deep network
literature.
So how do we do this?
Same thing I told you before.
Take an image, plop down all
these V2 receptive fields.
By the way, I should have
said this at the outset--
this is drawn as a cartoon.
The actual receptive
fields that we
use are smooth and overlapping,
so that there are no holes.
And in fact, the
details of that are
that since we're
computing averages,
you can think of this
as a low pass filter,
and we try to at least
approximately obey the Nyquist
theorem, so that
there's no aliasing--
that is, there's no
evidence of the sampling
lattice, for those of you that
are thinking down those lines.
If you were not thinking
down those lines,
I'll just say the
simple thing, which
is that they're not little
disks that are non-overlapping,
because then we would be
screwing everything up in
between them.
They're smooth
and overlapping so
that we cover the whole image,
and all the pixels in the image
are going to be affected
by this process.
So we make all
those measurements.
It's a very large
set of measurements.
And now we start with white
noise, and we push the button.
And again, push simultaneously
on the gradients
from all those little regions
until we achieve something
that matches all the
measurements in all
of those receptive fields.
The measurements in
the receptive fields
are averaged over
different regions.
So the ones that are
in the far periphery
are averaged over large
regions, and so those averages
are throwing away a
lot more information.
The ones that are
averaged near the fovea
are throwing away a small
amount of information.
When you get close
enough to the fovea,
they're throwing away nothing.
So the original image is
preserved in the center,
and then it gets more
and more distorted
as you go away from the fovea.
So the question is, does
that work for a human?
Is it metameric?
The display here
is not very good,
but I'll try to give you
a demonstration of it
to convince you
that it does work.
You have to keep your
eyes planted here,
and I'm going to
flip back and forth
between this original
picture, which
was taken in Washington Square
Park, near the department.
And I'm going to flip between
this and a synthesized version.
You have to keep your eyes here,
at least for a bunch of flips.
Hello.
Here we go.
Keep your eyes fixated.
Those two images
should look the same.
It's going back and forth,
A, B, A, B, and they
should look the same.
I think for most of you, and
for most of these viewing
distances, it should work.
And now if you look
over here, you'll
see that they actually
are not the same.
That's about the size
of a V2 receptive field,
and it is the same two images.
I'm not cheating here, in
case anybody's worried.
I'm just flipping back and forth
between the same two images.
And you can see that
the original image has
a couple of faces
in that circle,
but the synthesized one,
they're all distorted,
the same way Feynman was when
I showed you his photograph.
But again, the point here is
that these two are not metamers
when you look right at
this peripheral region,
but when you keep your
eyes fixated here,
they're pretty hard
to distinguish.
This is right at about the
threshold for the subjects
that we ran in this
experiment, so it should be
basically imperceptible to you.
That was a demo,
just to convince you
that it seems to work.
We did an experiment,
because we wanted
to do more than just show
that it sort of works.
We wanted to figure out whether
we could actually tie it
to the physiology in
a more direct way,
so what we did is
we generated stimuli
where we used different
receptive field size scaling.
So this is a plot.
Along this axis is going to be--
just to get you
situated, along this axis
is going to be
models that are used
to generate stimuli with
different receptive field size
scaling.
That's the ratio of diameter
to eccentricity-- diameter
of the receptive field to
the eccentricity distance
from the fovea.
And along here is going
to be the percent correct
that a human is able
to correctly identify--
the way we did this, it's
called an ABX experiment.
So we show one image, then
we show another image,
then we show a third image.
And we say, which image does
the third one look like?
So we're going to plot
percent correct here.
And if we use a model with
very small receptive fields,
then we get syntheses
that look like this.
This one has very
little distortion.
There's a little bit
of distortion around
near the edges, but it's
pretty close to the original.
If we use really
big receptor fields,
then we get a lot of distortion.
Things really start
to fall apart.
And somewhere in between--
so far to the
right on this plot,
we expect people to be at
100% noticing the distortions,
and far to the
left on this plot,
we expect them to be at chance.
We expect them to not be
able to tell the difference.
And that's exactly what happens.
This is an average
over four observers.
And you can see that the
performance, the percent
correct starts at
around 50%, and then
climbs up and asymptotes.
So what's more, we
can now do something--
this is a little bit complicated
to get your head around.
We're using this model
to generate the stimuli,
and this is the model parameter
plotted along this axis.
Now we're going to
use the model again,
but now we're going
to use the model
as a model for the observer.
So there's two models here.
One is generating the stimuli.
The other one, we're
going to try to fit--
we're going to ask, if we used
a second copy of the model
to actually look at
these images and tell
the difference
between them, what
would its receptive
fields have to be in order
to match the human data?
And I'm not going to drag
you through the details,
but the basic idea is
that allows us to produce
a prediction-- this black line--
for how this model
would behave if it
were acting as an observer.
And by adjusting the parameter
of the observer model,
we can estimate the size of
the human receptive fields.
So the end result
of all of this is
we're going to fit
a curve to the data,
and it's going to
give us an estimate
of the size of the
receptive fields
that the human is
using to do this task.
And that is right here.
In fact, it's right
at the place where
the curve hits the 50% line.
That's the point where the
human can't tell the difference
anymore, and that's
the point where
we think an observer would be--
where the receptive
fields of the stimulus
would be the same
size as the receptive
fields of the observer.
So that's what
we're looking for.
And when we do that
for our four observers,
they come out very consistent.
So here's a plot of the
estimated receptive field
sizes of these observers.
All four of them--
1, 2, 3, 4, and the
average over the four.
And nicely enough-- remember, I
told you that we know something
about the receptive
field sizes in--
these are macaque monkey.
And if we plot those
on the same plot,
these color bands are the
size of the receptive fields
in a macaque, now combined
over this large set of data
from a whole bunch
of different papers.
Jeremy went through
incredibly painstaking work
to try to put these all into
the same coordinate system
and unify the data sets.
And so the height of each
of these bars tells you--
they're error bars on how much
variability there is, where
we think the estimates are.
And you can see that the
answers for the humans
are coming right
down on top of V2.
So we really do think
that the information that
is being lost in these
stimuli is being lost in V2,
and it seems to match the
receptive field sizes at least
of macaque monkey.
We were worried that this might
depend a lot on the details
of the experiment.
So for example,
we thought, well,
what if we give people a
little more information?
For example, what if we let them
look at the stimulus longer?
So the original experiment
was pretty brief--
200 milliseconds.
What if we give them
400 milliseconds?
And so up here are plots
for the same four subjects.
The original task
is in the dark gray,
and you can see the curves
for each of the subjects.
When we give them more
time, what you notice
is that, in general,
they do better.
So generally, the
light gray curves--
1, 2, 3-- are above
the dark gray curves.
They get higher percent correct.
But the important thing is
that each of these curves
dives down and hits the 50%
point at the same place.
In other words, what we
interpret this to mean
is that the estimate of
the receptive field sizes
is an architectural
constraint, and we
can estimate the same
architectural constraint
under both of these conditions,
even though performance
is noticeably different, at
least for these three subjects.
This one, it's really quite
a big, big improvement.
This subject is doing
much, much better
on the task when we
give them more time.
And yet, this estimate
of receptive field sizes
is pretty stable,
so we thought this
was a pretty important control.
And down below is
another control.
That was a bottom-up control.
This is a top-down control.
People have talked
about attention
being very important
in peripheral tasks,
so we now gave the subjects
an attentional cue--
a little arrow at the
center of the display that
pointed toward the
region of the periphery
where the distortion was largest
in a mean-squared error sense.
So we measure little chunks
of the peripheral image
and look for the place where
there's the biggest difference,
and we tell them
to pay attention
to that part of the stimulus.
They're not allowed
to move their eyes.
We have an eye tracker
on them the whole time,
so they're not
allowed to look at it.
But we're telling them, try
to pay attention to what's,
let's say, in the upper left.
And again, the result
is quite similar.
Their performance improves
noticeably, at least
for these three subjects.
This one, again, is the
most dramatic performance
improvement.
Nobody gets worse.
This subject basically
stayed about the same.
But again, the estimates
of receptive field size
are quite stable.
So our interpretation
is attention
is boosting the signal,
if there is a signal, that
allows them to do the task.
But if they're at chance
and there's no signal,
attention does nothing, which
is why that when you get to 50%,
all these points coalesce.
All the curves are hitting
50% at the same place.
One last control-- we
wanted to convince ourselves
that really it was V2,
and it wasn't just luck
that we happened to get that
receptive field size that
matched the macaque data.
So we did a control
experiment where we tried
to get the same result for V1.
So this time, we just measure
local oriented receptive fields
like Hubel and Wiesel
described, and we average them
as in a complex cell over
different sized regions.
And we generate
stimuli that are just
matched for the average
responses of the V1 cells.
We don't do all the
statistics on top of that that
represents the V2 calculation.
We're just doing
average V1 responses.
When we do that--
we generate the stimuli,
we do the same experiment,
we get a very different
result in light gray here.
So you can see that
these curves are always
higher than the other
ones, but they also
hit the axis at a much,
much smaller value,
usually by about a factor
of two, which is just right,
given what I told you before
about receptive field sizes.
So if we go back and we combine
all the data on one plot--
down here are the V1 controls.
They're about the
right size for V1.
And up here is the original
experiment and the two controls
that I told you about--
the extended presentation
and the directed attention,
and those are all pretty much
lying in the range of V2.
We think this has a pretty
strong implication for reading
speed.
When you read, your eyes
hop across the page.
You do not scan continuously.
You hop.
And when you hop,
here's an example
of the kind of hops you
do when you're reading.
There's an eye position,
and the typical hop distance
would be about that--
from here to there.
This is the same piece of text.
We've synthesized it as a
metamer using this model, just
to illustrate the idea
that the chunk of stuff
that you can read around
that fixation point,
it's about right.
It matches what you
would expect for the kind
of hopping that you could do.
Your reading speed is limited
by the distance of those hops,
and the distance of
those hops is limited
by this loss of information.
So you can't read anything
beyond maybe this I and this N.
And in order to read it,
you hop your eyes over here,
and now you get
most of this word.
You can make out the rest
of an "involuntarily."
So there's an interesting
implication here,
which is that you
can potentially
increase reading speed by
using this model to optimize
the presentation of text.
And now that we can do
these things electronically,
you can imagine all
kinds of devices
where the word spacing
and the line spacing
and the letter sizes
and everything else
could change with time and
position on the display.
So you don't have to
just put things out
as static arrays of characters.
You could now imagine jumping
things around and rescaling
things.
You could imagine
designing new fonts that
caused less distortion or loss
of information, et cetera.
So this is just going back
to the trichromacy story
that I told you.
I told you that once they
figured out the theory,
and they had all the
psychophysics down,
the next thing that happened
is all that engineering.
They came up with
engineering standards,
and they used it to design
devices and specify protocols
for transmitting images,
for communicating them,
for rendering them.
I think that this has
that kind of potential.
And this theory is
too crude right now,
but if you had a really solid
theory for what information
survived in the
periphery, you can really
start to push hard on
designing devices and designing
specifications for devices
for improved whatever.
Sometimes you want
to improve things.
to make things harder
to see, like in this example.
So you want to build camouflage.
You go in, you take a bunch of
photographs of the environment,
and then you say, let's
design a camouflage
that best hides itself
when it's not seen directly
within this environment.
So you could use these
kinds of loss of information
to exploit things
or to aid things
in terms of human perception.
So let me say just a
few things about V2,
and then maybe I should stop.
So this work that
Jeremy and I did
in building this model
for metamers, which
is a global version
of the texture model
that operates in
local regions, led
us to start asking
questions about what
we could learn by actually
measuring cells in V2.
And we joined forces
with Tony Movshon,
who is the chair
of my department
and a longtime
collaborator and friend.
And we started a
series of experiments
to try to explore presentations
of texture to V2 neurons
to try to understand
what we could
learn about the actual
representations of V2.
And these are all done
in macaque monkey.
And I should also
mention that V2 is--
it's been studied
for a long time.
Hubel and Wiesel wrote a
very important paper about V2
in 1965, which was quite
beautiful, documenting
the properties that
they could find.
But the thing that's
interesting about this
is that V1 didn't really crack
until Hubel and Wiesel figured
out what the magic
ingredient was.
And the magic ingredient
was orientation.
Before Hubel and
Wiesel, people have
been poking at
primary visual cortex,
showing little spots of
light and little annuli--
all the things
that worked really
well in the retina and the
LGN, and they were not getting
very interesting results.
They were saying, well, the
receptive fields are bigger
and there are hot spots,
positive and negative regions,
but the cells are not
responding that well.
And when Hubel and
Wiesel figured out
that orientation was
the magic ingredient--
and the apocryphal story is that
they did that late at night,
and they figured it out
when they were putting
a slide into the projector,
and they had forgotten
to cover the cat's eyes.
And they put the slide
into the projector,
and the line at the edge of the
slide went past on the screen--
TOMMY: it was broken.
EERO SIMONCELLI: It was broken.
Ah, I always thought it
was the edge of the slide.
I've fibbed, and
Tommy has corrected me
that it was something
broken in the slide.
But in any case, the point
is that a boundary went by,
and they heard--
so they played the spikes
through a loudspeaker.
This is what most physiologists
did in those days,
and even still a lot do.
Certainly, in Tony's lab
you can always walk in there
and hear the spikes coming
over the loudspeaker.
Anyway, they heard this
huge barrage of spikes,
more than they had ever
heard from any cell
that they had recorded
from, and that
was the beginning of a whole
sequence of just fabulous work.
And using that tool--
very simple and very
obvious in retrospect,
but absolutely critical
for the progress.
The stimuli matter is the
point, and making the jump
to the right stimuli
changes everything.
So V2 for the last
40 years has been
sitting in this difficult
state where people
keep throwing stimuli at it.
They try angles.
They try curves.
They try swirly things.
They try corners.
They try contours of various
kinds, illusory contours.
And throughout all of
this, the end story
is V2 cells have bigger
receptive fields, many of them
respond to orientation,
some of them
respond to particular
combinations of orientation,
but it's usually a small subset,
and the responses are weak.
And that's really
what the literature
has looked like for 40 years.
So what we were after is, can we
drive these cells convincingly
and in a way that
we can document
is significantly different
than what we see in V1?
That was the goal--
find a way to drive
most of the cells
and to drive them
differently than what
one would expect in V1.
As a starting point, we
succeeded with textures.
So basically, we took
a bunch of textures.
Here are some example
textures drawn from the model.
Down below are
spectrally-matched equivalents.
So these things have the same
power spectra, the same amount
of energy and different
orientation and frequency
bands, but they lack all the
higher-order statistics that
are coming in this texture
model that give you nice,
clean edges and contours
and object-y things,
or lumps of objects.
And sure enough-- so
here's some example cells.
Here's three V1 cells.
Here's three V2 cells.
And in each of these
plots, there's two curves.
These are shown over time.
The stimulus is presented
here for 100 milliseconds.
You see a little
bump in the response.
And there's a light
curve and a dark curve.
The light curve is the response
to the spectrally-matched
noise, and the dark curve is
the response to the texture,
with the higher-order
statistics.
V1 doesn't seem to care
is the short answer here,
and V2 cares quite
significantly.
So when you put those
higher-order statistics in,
almost all V2 cells
respond significantly more,
and you can see that in
these three examples.
These are not unusual.
That's what most of
the cells look like.
So here's a plot, just showing
you 63% of the V2 neurons
significantly and
positively modulated.
And by the way, this is
averaged over all the textures
that we showed them.
And if you pick any
individual cell,
there's usually a
couple of textures
that drive it really
well, and then
a bunch of textures
that drive it less well.
So this effect could
be made stronger
if you chose only the textures
that drove the cell well.
And up here is V1, where you
can see that very few of them
are modulated by the existence
of these higher-order
statistics.
Oh, here it is across
texture category.
So now on the horizontal axis
is the texture category--
15 different textures,
and you can see, again,
that V1 is pretty much very
close to the same responses--
dark and light, again,
for the spectrally-matched
and the higher-order.
And for these three
V1 cells, they're
basically the same responses
for each of these pairs.
And for the V2 cells,
there are always
at least some textures where
there's an extreme difference.
So this is a really
good example.
There's a huge
difference in response
here for these two textures,
but for actually many
of the other textures, there's
not much of a difference.
So sort of a success.
And the last thing I was
going to tell you about
is that we think--
so this is really fitting,
given what Jim DiCarlo told you
about, or what I assume
he told you about--
this idea of tolerance or
invariance versus selectivity.
We wanted to know,
how can we take
what we know about
these V2 cells
and pull it back into
the perceptual domain?
How can we ask,
what is it that you
could do with a
population of V2 cells
that you couldn't do with
a population of V1 cells?
And the thought was if the
V2 cells are responding
to these texture
statistics, then
if I made a whole bunch of
samples of the same texture,
the V2 cells should be
really good at identifying
which texture that is--
which family it came from.
And the V1 cells will be
all confused by the fact
that those samples each
have different details that
are shifting around.
So the V1 cells will
respond to those details,
and they'll give a huge
variety of responses
invariant to re-sampling
from that family,
and the V2 cells will be
more invariant or more
tolerant to re-sampling
from that family.
That was the concept.
And that turns out
to be the case, so
let me show you the evidence.
So here's four
different textures,
four different-- what we
call different families.
Here's images of three different
examples drawn from each.
So these are just
three samples drawn,
starting with different
white noise seeds.
And you can see that they're
actually physically different
images, but they look the same.
Three again.
And so we got 100 cells from
V1 and about 100 cells from V2.
The stimuli are presented
for 100 milliseconds.
We do 20 repetitions each.
We need a lot of data.
And what's shown here are
just these this 4 by 3 array,
but we actually had
15 different families
and 15 examples of each.
20 repetitions of each of those.
225 stimuli times
20 repetitions.
That's the experiment.
So what we wanted to know
is, does the hypothesis hold?
And so here's an example.
These are responses laid
out for these 12 stimuli.
And what you can see is
that this is a V1 neuron--
a typical V1 neuron.
You can see that
the neuron actually
responds with a fair amount
of variety in these columns.
That is, for different
exemplars from the same family,
there's some variety.
High response here,
medium response here,
very low response here.
And this is for these
three images, which
to us look basically the same.
So this cell would not be
very good at separating out
or recognizing or helping in
the process of recognizing
which kind of texture you
were looking at, because it's
flopping all over the place
when we draw different samples.
That, as compared to
having to V2 cell--
this is a typical V2
cell, which you can see
is much more stable
across these columns.
This is roughly the same
response here, roughly the same
here, little bit of
variety in this one,
roughly the same in this one.
And sure enough, if you
actually go and plot this,
V2 has much higher
variance across families.
That's vertically.
These are the V1 cells.
These are the V2 cells.
And this is the variance
across families.
This is the variance
across exemplars.
V2 has higher variance
typically across families,
and V1 has higher
variance across exemplars.
And now if you take the
populations of equal size--
100 of each, and you
ask well, how good
would I be at taking
that population
and identifying which
family, which kind of texture
I'm looking at?
And we do this with
cross-validation
and everything.
I can give you the details
later, if you want to know.
We find V2 is always better
than V1 in doing this task.
So we can do a better job
in performing this task--
identifying which
of these families
a given example was drawn from
if we look at V2 than if we
look at V1.
And if we flip
that around and we
try to do exemplar
identification,
with 15 different examples
of a given family--
if we say, which one was it?
It turns out that V1 is
better than V2 for that.
So we think of this
as evidence that V2
has some invariance
across these samples,
whereas V1 is much
more specialized
for the particular samples.
This work started with
this fantastic post-doc
that I had mentioned
earlier, Javier Portilla.
Jeremy Freeman came
into my lab, and we just
jumped all over this
in making the metamers.
Josh McDermott is on
here because I usually
also play the auditory
examples and walk
through a little
bit of that work,
but I'm going to
leave that for him.
And Corey Ziemba, who's a
student who's in the lab
right now and is doing a
lot of the physiology and
did a lot of the physiology
that I showed you in Tony's lab.
And we were funded by
HHMI and also the NIH.
So thanks.